selon des faits vous parle pour toi
enfin
rappelle toi mon petit nous ont jusqu à
tim cook son dos messieurs vérifie ce
qui ne sont pas à 10 ans des gens
normaux mais les longues chasse dans les
forêts russes y ont trouvé un peu de
sang frais ici le sang frais ça s'achète
comme tout mais dans une ville juge ou
un monsieur qui est noble et qui est
assez bizarre mais quand même
et là l'humour son fils aussi mais ne
ressemble pas du tout à cunac vous savez
combien de films j'ai tourné celui ci se
nomme 131e vous avez combien de films de
émouvant de fantastique je tournais 14
ici le sens ça s'achète comme tout je
préfère le vin blanc beur